[Music]
two weeks until the nfl draft the
countdown is on and that's why we're
here every thursday at 1 pm eastern time
live in the bleacher report app i'm the
lead nfl draft analyst here at vr connor
rogers joined as always by stadium's
college football analyst michael felder
felder we got a loaded show today man we
are talking linebackers interior
defensive line we're looking at the afc
east we got some props how we feeling
right now
man i feel great i love this we're
breaking out a new segment that we're
trying out something that you and i
discussed offline is like one of those
times when you know you yeah you have a
little sip and you're like you know what
i got a great idea what if we tried this
so we're gonna see how it works out um
but these are the guys we love right so
we're talking linebackers and then we're
gonna talk about the guys that keep
those linebackers clean so they can go
out and make plays
that's right all right let's waste no
time let's start with the blue chip
linebackers we got a little face off
here a little anything you can do i can
do better felder and i each taking uh
one blue chip linebacker from this class
i'm rolling with utah's devin lloyd
felder is going with the champion
georgia's nakobi dean and we'll kick
things right off right now felder
looking at the run stopping the run
these guys are blue chippers for a
reason they don't come off the field
devin lloyd let's roll the tape let's
break it down and we're going to show
you this one a couple of times i love
his athleticism his sideline to sideline
range right here look at the eyes look
at the awareness look at where the play
is trying to draw him trying to draw him
one way the cut back but no light on the
feet turn the hips wrap up and make the
tackle don't leave your db in a
one-on-one situation felder those
corners they can come down and tackle
but let the linebackers do it let's roll
this back one more time after the tackle
at least one more time look at this read
the play stay patient don't over commit
but this is god given speed to get to
the sideline tfl in the stat sheet
felder devin lloyd bringing it against
the run one more time
awareness sideline range and of course
technique form wrap up the hips and
drive
let's see if the kobe dean can do that
felder
listen anything you can do i can do
better or anything lloyd can do dean can
do better and i'm going to look at this
play this is a play that should have
gone for a touchdown probably and as we
roll the play you're going to see dean's
lineup as an edge rusher he's not in the
he's not in the middle he's an edge
rusher here and what he does is
recognize the play
see it option okay not get caught up in
the wash and go make a touchdown saving
play because if this is a cut back
against that safety that's a touchdown
and that's the thing that he doesn't
allow to happen i love this out of
nekobi dean you see the rage you see the
awareness you see the ability i could
have picked a tackle for loss it would
have been ease he had plenty of but i
wanted to pick a play that showcases
that he can line up all over the defense
and still go make a play connor
man that's a long way to the football
and like you said that could be the
difference between saving six all right
let's see these guys in coverage right
now because we're not kidding blue
chippers do not come off the field three
down every down kind of backers devin
lloyd here felder i will take the easy
route this is called a pick six right
here for devon lloyd he's sitting in the
zone let's roll the tape here sitting in
the zone peeking at the running back
leaking out here peeking at a little
drop in the middle of the field knowing
that quarterback right there is just
looking to check it down and now i'm
taking the football and i'm taking it to
the house run it back one more time yes
it's a big play but how did we get here
look at him sitting here and just
reading the quarterback and checking
who's the smallest player on that side
of the field that's just gonna squat
right at the sticks i could try to just
knock this ball down i could try to wrap
up and make the tackle so there's no
yards given up but he knows the
quarterback wants the paper cup play
slowly cutting away at them and goes you
know what i'm going to make you pay for
that cut it off catch the ball not a lot
of linebackers could do that and then
run like a db for six i don't want my
offense back on the field i won't want
to flip the field i am putting points on
the board and i'll come back out on the
field right away to make another big
play devin lloyd in coverage he doesn't
want the small play he wants the big one
no i love that i love that he sits
sticks i to me like that's something
that i absolutely love that shows kind
of that football mentality right that in
you understand he's not gonna run this
route to five when he has to get four
he's gonna run it at four and sit at
four so that he can be a target to get
the first down and keep the drive going
and i love that about devin lloyd uh for
me i didn't go pick six he had a pick
six against florida where he comes down
takes the ball away runs it into the end
zone had an interception against auburn
where he tracks across the field and is
ready to make a tackle for loss but
instead gets an interception because
he's so aware i am going against
kentucky and this is what i love because
i like the little parts of football you
know me connor you know i like that
little nuance this is in the screen game
this play should be a touchdown
and what we see is everyone on george's
entire team
go towards the quarterback and then the
kobe dean's like oh
you guys all messed up but i am right i
will not be blocked i will get a tackle
for loss so here's my tackle for loss
for dean gets through two offensive
linemen makes that tackle for loss he's
able to get the job done if he's not
there that play is a touchdown and i
love his ability to make that happen and
understand it's not just about his
athleticism or his physicality it's
about what's between the ears this is a
guy that understands what's happening
before it happens and he goes no false
steps run it back one more time i want
to see robo run can we run let's do it
one more time i want to say it one more
time i i got to see it one more time
because i wanted folks to know watch
nicobed look at where he steps
everyone on that georgia defense they
take two hard steps to their left he
takes one step to the left and then he's
moving to his right this guy doesn't
misuse steps he eats up space he knows
what he's doing thank you for showing it
again i love what he brings to the table
it's my favorite nicoby dean play on
film felder just the pre-snap awareness
and then the ability to knife through
three blockers if one of those guys
stops him like you said it's a touchdown
that's what the kobe dean does so smart
before and after the snap all right
let's look at these guys
rushing the passer could be blitzing
could be as a pure rusher just affecting
the quarterback and we're kicking things
off with devin lloyd with his hand in
the dirt utah like to do this with him
he said you're not just an off ball
linebacker you see him on the bottom of
the screen there hand in the dirt
rushing wide off the outside shoulder of
that tackle look at him fire off the
ball cross face turn his hips and
register the quarterback hit
incompletion thrown too early or too
late whatever it is the quarterback felt
the heat from devin lloyd and once again
let's run through this this is an
off-ball linebacker a guy described as
an off-ball linebacker the most
important thing to watch here guys is
him firing off the snap hand in the dirt
watch the snap get off the ball now
watch the tackle set's too wide because
he's worried about the quickness worried
about getting beat outside on a soft
shoulder across his face lot of room to
work with this is something that aiden
hutchinson the projected number one
overall pick in this draft is known for
one more time one more time that's how
good of a play this is does not show up
in the stat sheet from an off-ball
linebacker hand in the dirt rush wide
cut inside now turn your hips right here
and flatten into the pocket hit the
quarterback break up the play get off
the field devin lloyd every down player
total disrupter makes big plays
i i love it like the fact that he can go
and this is this is your version of me
picking a hard play because you could
have picked a sack you could have picked
any of those but you picked a play where
he clearly was a disrupter did not allow
that completion to happen because he
forced the quarterback to throw the ball
too early this is where i take
it's not easy but i am taking the sack
instead of just the pressure uh because
listen every time you get a sack sack
adds up to money when it comes to the
nfl so when we look at nicoby dean and i
love this play you watch him
he had sacks against clips and he had
sacks against other teams i love this
play against arkansas for two reasons
one he comes a little too early right so
we're gonna see a pre-snap shift here
three-step shift then he comes down and
mugs up early but he's able to cross the
center's face for an a-gap pressure and
i love that he gets kj jefferson down on
the ground so there's two things that
we're gonna watch here people question
the kobe dean's size guess what a 300
pound center can't stop
so if you can't stop him as a 300 pound
center now what's the next question we
have a 250 pound quarterback does he
struggle getting him down on the ground
um no not really
so size isn't an issue strength isn't an
issue tenacity isn't an issue and we
know that he's one of the smartest
players in this entire draft you know
he's you know he's majored in mechanical
engineering
this guy's he's got it all i i'm going
to kobe dean over everything when it
comes to these blue chip linebackers
and i love how skinny he gets there with
that inside shoulder felder i don't want
a interior offensive lineman's hands
getting on me that could be the
difference between a pressure or
quarterback hit and landing the sack in
the stat sheet for nicoby dean so
great shout out to the control room at
bleacher report killing it on the film
game with the face off of blue chip
linebackers let's dive into the comments
right now eagles and 76ers says eagles
drafting lloyd at 18. alonzo soto says
felder's beard is always on point that
is right our little spoiler here right
now we got broncos mt saying not the
best but here's your sleeper troy
anderson montana state we're getting to
that one don't you worry and m coinan
says leo chanel is the best inside
linebacker in the class i will die on
that hill and that right there is the
transition i'm looking for because it's
time to talk about these pluggers at
linebacker the guys that live on the
inside do some dirty work and stop the
run let's kick things off with leo
chanel i'll die on that hill with you
felder right here this is a player that
very athletic coming downhill very
strong very explosive and he lives to
kill the run whether it's in between the
a gap the b gap this guy makes plays and
tries to get his team into better
situations for third downs those first
and second downs for chanel are key
plays and he is an excellent blitzer
yeah he's someone that's not afraid of
collisions and i listen
he is welcoming a car crash into his
life every single play the way that he
plays he'll take on a guard he's not
afraid to make a play i love that about
him so little chanel absolutely belongs
on the pluggers list he is so aggressive
and we've seen this right with wisconsin
linebackers they're so well taught when
you play for a guy who
you know wants defense to be ran the
right way he you get that job done so
these guys all they feel almost like
plug and play and we talk all the time
about georgia or alabama and guys being
kind of built from a mole but
wisconsin's linebackers fit into that
same that it fit into that same mix and
and i'm going to throw another guy out
there to you connor uh coy walker from
georgia because i think he fits into
that same mold as well as a guy that
just he's plug and play like you tell me
the difference between kwai walker and
like rolando mclean right in terms of
what you want out of a linebacker from
that's going to play in your interior
yeah he's somebody that reminded me of
logan wilson who had a nice season for
the bengals this year a former wyoming
linebacker guys that they give you
enough lateral ability to get you see
them running right there to the sideline
they could take away running backs in
the flats but belder they don't give a
lot in the middle of the defenses which
is what i love about them you've got to
be able to move all around in this
league at linebacker it's tough to be a
guy that just sits in the middle of the
field and is just taking on fullbacks
and collisions with guards over and over
again there's a place for you on early
downs but if you want to stay on the
field and you don't want to just be a
sub package player i think that's what's
so impressive with kwai walker yes
nicoby dean gets the love yes the
defensive line in front of him uh was
borderline historic to be honest with
you but in his own way kway walker made
awesome awesome plays so felder i know
you love this georgia defense what'd you
see with him
i i think he's a better version of what
people thought alec ogletree was coming
out of coming out of college
he is not afraid of contact we saw there
the big the big thing i loved the clips
that we showed was his ability to defeat
the cut against tennessee and he can
play in the interior even though they
played him outside because they had a
wealth like let's be real connor georgia
had a wealth of remarkably talented
linebackers so they were able to bump
him outside a little bit when he
probably should have been playing inside
a little bit more but he was able to get
the job done and
again defeating a cut is a hard thing to
do a lot of guys try to jump over it a
lot of guys don't get their hands down
but him jamming down the cut means for
me i know that he can take on guards i
know that he can take on full backs
tight ends whatever but defeating the
cut that puts him kind of that no pun
intended but kind of a cut above other
guys that i'm gonna ask to play in the
interior uh doing things that a lot of
other guys don't want to do
all right let's dive into the comments
looking at these linebackers as well
here we got detroit sports 69 says what
linebackers will be available for
detroit at 32 34 or 66
i think you're looking at two of the
guys we just mentioned i think at 32 we
could see a guy like nakobi dean b there
just because of his size it's not a
knock on him as a player it's just
traditionally how the position falls so
i wouldn't rule out nakobi dean with 32
or 34 66 we got some more names uh to
come for you uh buying and trying says
malcolm rodriguez is a big time sleeper
i agree with you there felder malcolm
rodriguez ultra ultra productive player
in the big 12 this year
yeah listen he runs around like crazy
this guy's got his hair on fire like
he's he goes side light in the sideline
and we talked about sideline the
sideline we talked about uh chanal but
like he's got that same thing like he
doesn't ever have to come off the field
i love what he brings to the table
all right let's take a look at these
every down linebackers have seen a lot
of love for troy anderson in the
comments we're going to get there in a
minute but we're going to start with
chad mumma from wyoming this is someone
that got to participate in the senior
bowl obviously had a tremendous career
there at wyoming felder you look at
mumma he's somebody that can play a
traditional mic role i think that's what
makes you so excited about him but once
again doesn't really surrender anything
in the way of athleticism super
explosive i've seen him stay sticky with
running backs coming out of the
backfield but can take on contact mumma
looks like a round two plug and play
starter
yeah the thing with mumma we had this
debate is he a plugger or is he an every
down guy and we're watching here where
he's showing the athleticism to make him
an every down guy and i think that's
really cool for him it's really cool for
what he brings to the tape what he has
is in terms of his skill set his toolbox
if you will is he's someone that yeah
i can come down i can take my read step
take that hard read step
redirect go make a play as we talked
about with devin lloyd and with nicoby
dean he can do all those same things and
fill a gap but he also has the ability
to play a little bit in coverage he can
as you mentioned stick to wide receiver
excuse me stick the running backs but i
think he's still at his best at the box
and
for all the discussion about you know
sub packages and
teams going 11 or 10 personnel
at some point you're going to come up
against a team that plays 12 or plays 21
and guess what mumma's going to be your
guy on the field because
he's the one that can cover some of
those guys and go make plays
all right let's move to the man of the
hour in the comments troy anderson from
montana state
what a road it's been for him felder
obviously he was somebody that has an
unconventional path to being a
linebacker prospect he's been productive
at running back in college he's been all
conference at quarterback in college now
it seems like he's found his long-term
home ultra athlete believe he has a
track background in high school i
believe he's from the state of montana
somebody that
you can see this guy has played both
sides of the ball for a long time and
he's an every down linebacker because of
that athleticism to constantly make
plays run and chase but be a tough guy
in the middle of the field i think the
awareness is still coming
along for somebody that you know has not
played this position his entire life
consistently but felder the upside with
troy anderson is going to lead to him
being a top 50 pick in this draft
yeah he's got like it's it's like a
leighton van der ish light right like is
that crazy to say
yeah he reminded me a little bit of
kenneth murray just running around like
a maniac trying to make plays in space
that's a good kenneth murray that's a
good one because he was running all over
the place um yeah when you watch
troy anderson like you see all the tools
now we just got to get all that directed
in the right way every play so that we
can make things happen uh you want to go
to the comments connor
let's take a look here master search
says troy anderson and brandon smith
they'll be pro bowlers might not be
taken till the third or even the fourth
which will be a huge mistake i'll give
you this master search and troy anderson
goes in the second round i do think
brandon smith might hang around there on
the board uh one more here for you
felder from alonzo soto says well the
eagles finally go linebacker in the
first they have two first rounders
belder with one of those first rounders
you going with your boy nakobi dean for
the eagles it's a big need
i would i mean why wouldn't you i mean
he's so good the guy like we did the
whole thing like if if either one of
those guys are sitting there lloyd or
dean why would you not pick them if
that's a big need and you haven't when's
the last time we the eagles have had a
linebacker that people were excited to
talk about they don't do it they don't
take them in the first round and like
we've said that's a trend that should
change it would help philadelphia and it
would go a long way for them all right
let's move on to our last linebacker
group the chase linebackers the running
chase guys these are guys that can play
in space they might start out as sub
package players nickel dimebackers money
backers that's sometimes what the nfl
calls them now belder i'll throw the
first one to you brian assamoa from
oklahoma what have you seen with him
over the years
well we've already talked about kenneth
murray right coming out of this a
similar system but this is the guy like
he literally will run you down as we're
watching right there right he is
a little undersized but you see him here
all these clips are the way that he's
able to use his speed to be
influential
in place he's able to run guy this is
him running down crosses we see him
running down a quarterback running down
a running back from the backside chasing
down a scrambling quarterback he is not
the biggest guy but he is someone that
you can sit on the back side of the
defense read backside and he can still
make plays on play side so if you talk
about so if you go offensive strength is
over here
and he's lined up here
and you get some resistance on this side
he's going to be able to zoom it over
and make a play from the backside and i
think that's really cool about these
guys because chase linebackers are super
important linebackers that can chase
often times we call them the will right
your will linebacker is a guy that can
run things down from the backside if you
gunk it up clog it up on the front side
they're going to be the guys that make
those tackles so i absolutely love to
see
chase linebackers guys who go make plays
and and one of the biggest things for me
connor is putting a chat i hate putting
a chase linebacker a guy that should be
a chase linebacker
into a mic or a stan or a sam situation
because they're not built for that which
is which leads us to christian harris
nailed it great transition felder i
think that's been the problem with
christian harris somebody that i've been
a little lower on than the consensus
that sees him as a top 50 pick the
position he was put in at alabama things
did not look great he gets lost in
traffic he can get eaten up by blocks
but the athleticism tells you with a
position switch that keeps him clean
that lets him run in chase that lets him
see ball get ball there might be a lot
of meat left on the bone for him to have
a better nfl career and the one thing to
know about christian harris here felder
that four four four forty that is in the
97th percentile this is one of the
fastest linebackers we have ever seen
entering the nfl draft
yeah he can run and that's what he's
good at like you see him here playing on
play side and when he's clean he makes a
play you're cleaner coming from that
chase side so you can run things down uh
let's transition to another guy jojo
domon a kid coming out of nebraska i
remember him coming out as a safety
ah goodness was bo pelini still the
coach there during that time i mean he
was a safety out of colorado
and he just he's transitioned from
safety to linebacker obviously you see
him here as a blitzer
he's aggressive he's angry he's mean he
plays in their sort of their peso
package as that money linebacker that
you mentioned but you see him there
great body control as long as he doesn't
have to
confront guards consistently confront
tight ends or tackles you see him there
running it down from the backside which
is exactly what we're talking about
running it down again coming from the
back side of the plate even though the
strong he's lined up to the strong side
in that play against ohio state he comes
the play side is opposite him and he
runs from the play from the strong side
to the play side to make a play
as long as you can keep him clean he's
going to run it down i think that he is
um
conor helped me out here what's his name
shaq shaq is it shaq thompson that play
for the panthers yes yep yeah i think
he's got a lot of that safety to
linebacker transition and if you can
keep him clean he can be productive
yeah my player comparison right there
felder quan alexander light maybe not as
talented of a player but the same style
of player where he signed you love him
on the field as a nickel backer you can
run with running backs run with tight
ends but you got to keep these guys out
of the traffic so you see the chase
linebackers recap right here let's go to
the comments right now yt29 giving leo
chanel some love saying chanel is
linebacker one he also said first round
linebacker is not worth it the value is
in the second and third old sport new
york city says jojo that boy a problem
randy babara says how come no one ever
talks about demarco jackson someone is
going to get lucky on day three another
guy felder that i think would have fit
this run and chase mold problem here is
guys we could be here until 5 pm eastern
time we go through every linebacker but
we got to do the interior defensive line
so let's go right to it and start with
the run stuffers right now and who to
start who better to take over this
category than the big man that ran
jordan davis right here
felder i call him a bigger wince vince
wilfork that is one of the scariest
comparisons i have ever written down in
my draft sheet since i've been doing
this vince wilfork was an absolute
terror on the interior for new england
he can control three blockers he eats
space he could run at that size jordan
davis man i know he wasn't on the field
all the time for georgia but when he was
a total difference maker for the middle
of the defense
yeah the big thing with jordan davis and
i'll be quick here because i know we got
we want to get to these other guys we've
talked a ton of jordan davis but the
biggest thing with jordan davis for me
is i think the sec championship game
changed who he was as a player
he
seemed over the course of the season to
be a little bit more content with that
role that he had where he's like i play
first down i play second down i'm off
the field uh they're in this personnel
package i'm off the field like watching
him against alabama look at the
sidelines like he's he's not rushing the
passer really he's just got arms
extended and he's looking at the
sideline like coach i'm not supposed to
be in the game and then obviously they
lose and then watching the tenacity that
he brought to the national championship
game and the michigan game i think that
changed him as a player he's a guy that
does want to be on the field he wants to
try to be a three down guy he wants to
create penetration i think that goes a
long way so yeah he is clearly the blue
chip um
run stuffer if you will
you mentioned vince wilfork i would say
like i think he's
he's yeah bigger vince wilfork or more
athletic terence cody he's got all those
things in his toolbox
and i think he got activated by losing
his sec championship game to use him
all right let's move on staying though
in the sec looking at neil farrell jr
from lsu
this is the definition of run stuff
right here felder this is your two gap
big body take up space let the
linebackers come in and make the play
but man he's got a role in this league
you see the draft projection there
rounds four to five he's had a really
nice process it's not just the senior
ball but the ability i think he turned
it on a notch this year felder and there
were some times against the pass that he
showed he's he's working on becoming a
better rusher a more active rusher you
see the pursuit against the quarterback
after the botched snap but i think when
you look at him you're talking about
shade nose maybe three tech at times but
you really like him playing right over
the center and taking up a lot of space
and helping out a team on early downs
and in goal line situations
so he plays zero to three right so what
we're talking about is head up over the
center
to a shade to in that one in the a gap
to inside shoulder of the guard to
outside shoulder of the guard
what how what's his capital look like in
this draft connor like where can he
where do you see him being picked at
round four round five and a lot of that
is because the d-line class is a little
thin after the first couple guys go but
he's very role specific but
it's a role that matters still in the
nfl you got to stop the run
i i dig that i just wanted to get that
take on it because i think he's a really
good player but i do think i view him as
someone
if you're gonna play the twos like you
know that old jimmy johnson style where
you have two twos instead of having a
shade and a shade and a three i think he
fits perfect in that but there's not
that many teams that do that although we
do see a lot of teams go with guys that
are lined up in the twos or guys that
are lined up in that kind of a two i or
three i like that that head up situation
with standing edge rushers he fits into
that really really well because we can
see him get penetration but we can also
see him eat up two blocks the center in
the guard or the guard in the tackle to
still control that space so linebackers
can go make plays um who else do we got
we got um travis jones big boy uconn yes
yeah this guy's he's humongous
felder he's one of quietly one of my
favorite players in the entire nfl draft
travis jones and i'll be the first to
tell you guys i was late i got down on
the field for senior bull drills and
this guy came out like a heavyweight
boxer with a club move that he was
knocking guys out left and right he is
not just he's in the run stuffers and
that's the name of his game he's a
classic nose tackle he is a guy that he
can eat up space he can stop the run but
he showed me something in one on one
pass russian drills builder he can be a
big time bully and let me say this with
travis jones jordan davis spoiled his
combine party he is over six foot four
he is 325 pounds he ran a 4 9 2 40. that
is terrifying if jordan davis didn't
have a historic combine everybody would
be talking about travis jones he's a
first-round player he is a three-down
player he is an impact player felder i
love this guy and if he falls out of the
first round it's not gonna be very long
before his name is called on day two
yeah i listen we this is the category is
called run stuffers
but i think in the case of davis and
jones we're talking about guys that are
swallowers right like
they they eat up blocks
they swallow space
and then they make a running back make a
decision do i run around over there
where the fast guys are that are going
to get me on the ground or do i just
kind of like stay behind these guys that
have eaten up all this space and can't
be moved i've got to do they make
running backs make a choice and that's
what i love about them
all right let's get into the comments
here david shepard says do you all think
devante wyatt falls down to the chiefs
at 29. we're going to get into devonta
wyatt conversation a little bit that
might be a little late for him felder's
eyes lit up at that one alonzo soto says
neil farrow is going to go in the fifth
but it's gonna be a steal he definitely
has a lot of potential i think we agree
with that one all right let's get to the
jack-of-all-trades defensive lineman
here right the guys that could do yeah
can do a little bit of everything and
felder want to start with a bit of a
deep cut here that i like that you
brought up on the pre-production call
because he played true nose tackle in
college made a lot of plays does not get
a lot of love we're looking at john
ridgeway in this defensive line class
yeah i love john ridgway i think he i
think he's the heart and soul that
arkansas defense a defense that was much
improved i mean this is a guy look if
you see him there rip him off get off me
i'm gonna make a play so it's not just
that he's able to eat the space he's
able to disengage and then go make a
tackle and i like that out of his game
he always wants to be involved in the
play if there's a play that's happening
at the line of scrimmage against
arkansas ridgeway is going to be
involved in it you see him there get
disengaged move down line i think
ridgeway is an underrated player
obviously the commenter just said that
neil farrell would be a steal i think
ridgeway is going to be a steal as well
he's going to be someone that gets into
that defensive line room defensive line
room and is just
he's going to be they're going to love
him they're going to want to play with
him he's going to get on the field and
he is again someone that can play
probably from a zero to a three maybe a
four i uh depending on the package but
he has these there's some scheme
versatility to him he did play that true
nose but he can do more than that and we
see that with the ribs and he's got
these subtle moves the ability to
to rip to dip the ability to swim to get
to get himself clean so that he's not
just occupying space to spill or space
to bounce he's also making tackles
all right let's move on to perrian
winfrey the pass rusher the interior
defensive lineman from oklahoma another
guy a little bit of a roller coaster
season for him felder a questionable fit
in that defense but someone that once
again at the senior bowl was unblockable
him and travis jones were the two guys
that could not be blocked against top
tier competition i look at winfrey
felder and i see somebody that can be a
true gap shooter at the next level if
you let him pin his ears back and work
the interior line it's a little too
quick for guards right there you see him
get off the block get downhill make the
tackle for a loss i thought he ran a
little hot and cold in college i think
he's somebody that in the right coaching
fit somebody can light that fire he
could be not just a situational pass
rusher or a decent player but a really
really high-end impact player inside
well here's the thing conor the question
that i have to use where do you play him
i'm gonna say three tech and i'm not
gonna say every down three tech i think
he's coming into the league and this is
why he won't go in the first two rounds
in my eyes i think he comes into the
league and you're going all right
passing down third and long we are going
to put a package out there where we want
our best rushers on the field we don't
trust you against the run yet the read
and react to containing but we're gonna
look at a scheme with a front four that
says get home and he can do that from
inside
but
will we not play him as a five tech on
rundowns you don't trust him to play
five tech on rundowns
i'm up and up and down on that felder
i've seen two perry on whimperies in my
life one during the season that i said
man you're a lot better than this and
then one in the all-star circuit where i
said you're the best player on the field
all three practices which one is it
going to be when we get to the nfl
yeah that's that's the question i have
with him because
his body to me
says five tech
his technique and his game
says three tech
so we're looking at a guy that can play
what from from five to three
and yeah it's just none of it it's
you're gonna have to
perry and winfrey is a good football
player the coach is gonna have to be
even better to find a way to scheme him
success that's and that's in are you
going to design your entire defense
around a guy that
basically you don't know what position
he plays
i don't he's not warren sapp like i
don't know what you're going to do
felder we got a comment here that i want
to interrupt you with that i know you'll
love nicoby dean will be the most
impactful hybrid linebacker in this
draft mark my word he's got that a mic
singletary motor from sil
bimmons all aboard the felder hype train
for nakobi dean let's keep this train
rolling right here got a little caught
up fadarian mathis felder i feel like
you and i are the only ones carrying the
flag at this point from darien mathis he
gets no love he's not the most explosive
guy he's not the most athletic guy he's
not the biggest guy but he is a jack of
all trades interior defensive lineman i
think he does things really well that
you only can see on tape builder it's
read and reacting to the run it's
understanding when to contain it's
understanding when to push forward to
get to the sideline or hold your spot
just a really intelligent smart football
player felder a team captain at alabama
that means something on the inside for a
guy that wasn't a superstar but had no
problem doing the dirty work week after
week
that's the thing this guy like
i know you've seen pulp fiction this is
your wolf right
this is the guy that you call when you
need some dirty work done and that's
what he does and i love that about him
he shows up
he doesn't ask for much he doesn't need
to be on the he doesn't need to be on
the cover of the cereal box he don't
need to be on the cover of the of the
program he shows up and i i love that
about federia mathis he's on our jack of
all trades because we've seen him play
basically from a zero to a five he's
done all those things and
he doesn't have the numbers that other
people really like but what he does have
is the ability to always do his job he's
one of those guys when i watch him and
i'm sure this is the case in alabama he
grades out incredibly high based upon
what his assignment is the problem is
most people don't understand what his
assignment is part of his assignment is
i got to get this guard to move over
here so that my linebacker can hit that
a gap and he does that really well and i
love the little way he grabs the little
grabs that he has
to move a guard over on a blitz the
little grab as he's moving to move a
guard over on a blitz or the linebacker
and get into the a gap uh the the subtle
like the little cha-cha that he does to
make sure that the center pays attention
to him before he goes out to loop on a
te game i i think that he does all these
little things really well he's going to
be we mention it with ridgeway but i
think he's going to be a treat he's
going to be a true delight in the locker
room as a guy who he comes in um as an
old soul if you will and i think that's
a big thing that i really love because
there's some defensive line coaches in
college that let you get away with
athleticism there's other ones that
teach you the craft and he clearly has
picked up on the craft
i'm with you felder i compared him to
harrison phillips a guy that just does
all this dirty work on the inside
technically sound uh stout and tough and
you know doesn't really get enough love
and those are the harrison phillips just
got paid after quietly productive years
in the nfl doing that dirty work on tape
all right let's move on to
maybe viewed as the cream of the crop on
this interior defensive line class and
that is devonte
wyatt in this trap elder i know you are
a big fan we've talked about him in the
top 20 of this draft before i project
him to go in round one really that jack
of all trades player felder that has
been really good against the run has
shown explosive nature against the pass
remind me a little bit of deron payne
coming out a jack of all trades can have
some explosive impact plays and here you
go you can see it he plays all over he
can play shade knows he could obviously
play five tech three tech felder devonte
wyatt has had a great season and has
made himself into a round one pick
yeah i i think he can play from zero to
five depending on you know down and
distance and whatnot we see him here
he's lined up in a in a four in a in the
four
four position he's not quite a five in
that in that spot but he can line up out
there he can do everything i've had
multiple fans talk about well he wasn't
super productive his numbers and i'm
like that's not what they asked him to
do
they asked him to keep linebackers clean
they asked him to make sure that he
alley he made sure that ali was clean
for scene for dean for walker like for
for tyndall that's not what they ask
them to do you get them to the nfl you
turn them loose this guy's going to be a
wrecking ball
and
i don't he's my favorite defensive
tackle in this draft if we're being
quite honest
i know other people have uh jordan davis
above him
but
people i i personally think that devonta
wyatt's the number one is dt1
in this draft because of his scheme
versatility there's not a thing he can't
do in this draft and that's not the same
case for a lot of these other guys
all right let's look at the comments
real quick before we get to some
tweeners some pass rushing guys felder
and i have had a long conversation on
that group in this trap master searches
laugh out loud ridgeway was honestly one
of the first late round gyms i looked at
six weeks ago when i first started
looking at the draft well the jets draft
i should say shout out to master search
jets fans always in here uh having a
good time old sport new york city says
logan hall will go higher than mathis
well
we're gonna get to logan hall in this
next group this is the pass rushers
breakdown on the interior but we're
gonna start with de marvin liao felder
somebody that i find to be the ultimate
tweener in this draft he can rush the
passer inside he's not somebody that i
ultimately trust against the run right
now think you look at the tape against
alabama and yes it was alabama but guess
what the nfl doesn't get much easier
struggled to contain struggled to hold
his ground but when you ask him to
simply pin his ears back and go see him
running stunts get him involved in
rushing the passer he's going to be an
impact player he's not a true edge he's
not a true interior defensive line
player and i think that's going to make
him very scheme specific felder but in
the right early down roll he could find
some success strictly rushing the
quarterback
well he's the rare defensive tackle that
doesn't want to be touched you know
like is that a crazy thing to describe
him as
no it's he plays like he's a stand-up
edge right like a nick benito or a guy
like that but he's lined up with his
hand in the dirt inside
so yeah no he he just he's always
finding trying to find ways to slip
blocks to get blocks off of him which
gives him a wide array of possible pass
rush moves but
they're gonna run the ball up first and
second down
i need you to sit there and hold this
gap
and so that's what puts him in the pass
rusher category we had a long talk about
this pre-pro um that's what puts him
into this category is
his ability to slip to make himself
skinny i know you mentioned it with
nicoby dean but he's got this ability as
a guy that's what close to 300 pushing
300 pounds the ability to to get skinny
and slip through and i really love i
love that about him i just don't know i
think early on package player and then
we grow him into
what we need on rundowns which is going
to be interesting and let's go ahead and
get to logan hall man
he is
he's another guy like for being how big
he is to make himself skinny is really
beautiful
it is he's destructive on the inside a
lot of guys that play at that weight
around 280 or so at college 270. it's
hard for them to hold up at 3 tech but
he didn't look like he didn't look lost
at all on that for me he's a taller
dominique easley felder and i know
that's a name that fell out of the nfl
strictly because of the knee injuries
the talent was always there to be
explosive off the ball to use your
length to swim over blockers obviously
the craziest thing with logan hall to me
is that sideline range he's somebody
that the backside pursuit is excellent
so his role might be a little bit
different at the next level you might
have a team draft him and say listen we
think with your build you're going to be
a dominant 5 tech we like your length we
like your explosive nature we don't want
you to continue to gain weight we don't
ever need you to be 295 pounds and play
on the inside as you're gonna see here
on the highlight tape that's how houston
used him and they tested him with that
earlier and you see the swim move right
there and then the long strides of the
quarterback
felder he could quietly be one of the
most destructive players to be taken in
round two this year
yeah i think that's the destructive is a
great one you see him there punching the
hands down and then walking the guy back
into the ball carrier i love to see that
you see him again here explode off the
ball get full extension and then run run
run run run run
you want to see a guy that can run you
want to see someone i love the side
light and sideline run and how how crazy
is going to be
houston having just houston churning out
another defensive lineman let's go so
it's really good for them but it's also
really cool to watch
him a different guy he's not in the same
mold as that oliver oliver was a
technician uh is the way that i would
describe him him jonathan allen those
guys were technicians i think paul is
explosive and disruptive and
i i like that disruptiveness the ability
to be or truly just
a play killer
and
or a play exploder where
he's gonna get penetration and in the
run game i trust him more than leal in
the run game because at least i know
that he's gonna get penetration in the
run game that's positive penetration
that leads to the play getting funneled
back somewhere versus i just don't want
to be blocked i think he works to defeat
blockers whether it's walking them back
into the ball carrier or finding a gap
and then pushing making it flat pushing
it wide so that the linebacker knows
where they're supposed to go but both of
these guys belong in the pass rusher
category because
if it's third and 17
cut them loose and let them go
all right let's take a look at the
comments here david shepard says where's
a good fit for logan hall from houston i
think seattle in that 40 and 41 range uh
they took malik mcdowell in the second
round a couple years ago they like
athleticism and different body types on
their front four that they can move all
around and one more here from old sport
new york city says haskell garrett low
round beast out of ohio state i think
you'll want to stick around i think
belder's got something on that yeah
felder you want to hop in now or you
want to save it for later
i'm going to save it for later listen
we're going to get to the dolphins and
we're gonna talk a little haskell
garrett baby
he was one of the guys for those a
little peek behind the curtain
they like to put a cap on connor and i
for how many guys we get to talk about
and so i try to find a way to slide him
into the show in a different space but
we're going to get to haskell carrot for
sure
all right so let's get to the divisional
breakdown it is the afc east today and
we're going to have some fun with this
one and we're going to kick off
with the beast of the afc east and that
is the buffalo bills man they are loaded
with talent they are locked and ready to
go and they are looking primed to try to
get to the super bowl but before they do
that they got some needs on the board
here to address here felder we're
looking at corner guard maybe linebacker
maybe another wide receiver for josh
allen in this spot so starting off with
the bills here felder you're picking
25th in this draft what are you looking
at for buffalo right now
i mean it feels like this is kind of the
consensus right kenyan green like i know
you love him and he's a guy that just
he we've seen him play right tackle
we've seen him play guard he's played
all over the offensive line
he's in a he's
an elite talent i wouldn't call him an
elite prospect but he's certainly an
elite talent along the offensive line
we're seeing him play left guard right
here
how do you feel about that with their
first pick first round pick going kenyon
green
i like it felder i think the bill's
dream scenario it's a dream for a reason
trent mcduffie's probably not going to
be there at 25 for them so you got to
start thinking about other options
here's my thought on and i want to know
if you agree with this felder kenyan
green they never let him get comfortable
it felt like he played four spots on the
offensive line left tackle right tackle
left guard right guard when you turn on
the tape and for the bills he would be a
guard when you turn on the tape and
strictly strictly watch the guard reps
that is when he looked more comfortable
he was doing less thinking and pass pro
and it unlocked that bully nature in the
run game to move people very very far
out of the way so felder do you think
that can help him a lot just having a
home where his best tape has been in
college as he moves on to the nfl as a
potential round one pick yeah i think
you're spot on i think settling into
guard and just you know listen you know
listen we've all moved before right and
home doesn't feel like home until you
got all your stuff unpacked if you're
worried about the next job or the next
move you don't you never feel
comfortable so if you let him get
comfortable at guard stretch out on the
couch he's going to be what he is and
that's a bully i listen i think he is
a plused up maybe version of jamari
sawyer although i'd argue about the
plused up part i think him and sawyer
are very comparable with respect to
playing guard uh but kenyan green at
guard
feels that does feel like someone who's
at home
they got a pot of coffee brewing they
know they're gonna go out on the balcony
that afternoon
and and watch the cars go by he feels
good he's loving it he's got his robe on
doing his thing yeah i understand that i
said a robe in the afternoon it doesn't
matter he's he's that's how comfortable
he is he didn't get dressed all day and
what that translates to for the bills is
a guy that's moving bodies on sunday and
that's what you want him to be doing
all right builder let's move over to the
patriots we saw the needs there corner
wide receiver linebacker safety and
maybe a little edge pass rush here i'll
kick this one off looking at some value
at wide receiver pick 85
john metchi from alabama maybe the
forgotten man somehow the wide receiver
group yes the season-ending injury is
the reason but turn on the tape and
there's tape with him playing with mac
jones so this isn't any uh unfamiliar
nature he can come in and be ready to go
with that injury healing up to play with
mac with mechy for me felder i love the
polish in the routes i think there's
times where there's some questionable
drops but i think his body control his
route running understanding spacing and
you see right there the changing gears
is something that would be valued in new
england offense that needs playmaker i
don't think they'll use a first round
pick that's not their nature on a
playmaker but on day two
this guy because he got hurt is somebody
that you can squeeze a little bit more
value of later on
no i love betchie i think he's great and
i love that last clip we showed against
miami where we see him tempo his routes
out everybody thinks route running is
just about cuts and breaks but it's
about tempoing them to understand when
you're supposed to be open great job
with that metchy has it in spades
something they teach really well in
alabama um i'm gonna go listen i'm gonna
go big or go home and i'm gonna give you
two options here right
first round daxton hill from michigan
safety
swiss army knife guy this guy's a
leatherman he can do anything for you
i love the fact that he played that that
nickel corner but he was also ready to
blitz off the edge you see him there
tackle for loss plays in that slot he's
able to get that job done but he's also
not afraid to go out and make tackles
you see him here sinking into coverage
to make the interception i love what he
brings to the table his ability to
attract guys and man here boom no don't
worry guys get down or lay down i love
that um so daxton hill and then i'm
going to stick in the big 10 for you
connor because we're talking first round
here and then the next pick they had
like the next one i'm talking about is
when we get into like what 120 something
130s
nick cross another big 10 safety
like how big is the gap between hill and
cross because if you can't get hill can
you get cross
man i listen i think cross cause of his
athleticism is starting to climb right
and it's a great question are you going
to use the first round pick on dax hale
are you going to look late on day two
maybe the top of day three for cross who
who ultimately might sneak into the
third round here i think felder for me
it's just it's polish at this point
cross has all the athleticism in the
world he has highlight real plays then i
look at dax hill the first line of my
scouting report a dream coverage chess
piece for a defensive coordinator he
could play in the slot he could play too
high he could play single high i just
think his eyes awareness the ability to
drive down on the ball and zone coverage
that short area change of direction new
england loves these guys that could do a
little bit of everything in the
secondary so it's a question of are you
gonna bet on the athlete in cross which
is way better value and you think you
can coach him up which new england
always thinks that with these kinds of
players or you're going to go with
jackson hill where let's be real he's
one of the most complete packages of the
dbs in this draft
i got one more thing
because this you you mentioned your
notes the notes that i looked at
for me with jackson hill the first thing
i have is
he is what people thought jabril peppers
would be
bingo
bingo yeah yeah all right let's go let's
go to the dolphins man and i know we
want to talk about your guy
dolphins if we look at their team needs
the dolphins have center linebacker
offensive tackle corner t e
um they're stick they're riding it out
with tua so they got jalen waddle
they're ready to rock and roll in a
couple of those positions but you got
cole strange on the list and so let's
introduce people to cole strange from
chattanooga but also
do you think that cole strange is
someone that moves into
do you think cole strange is someone
that moves into that um the center
position or does he stick it guard
it's a great question felder and they're
such a fascinating team because their
first pick is at 102. so that's why you
and i are checking into the cole strange
bucket right a small school player you
turn on the tape against kentucky
because you go okay small school player
let's see how he tested against the big
guys the nfl kind of guys looked great
athletic grip strength bully plays
through the whistle plays after the
whistle i i wonder because of the size
or just because that level of confidence
because the need here for the dolphins
at center is that something he can do i
think it is i think long term you would
love to see him at guard they are in
mike mcdaniel's scheme they are going to
value the athleticism to do this climb
to linebackers cut them off turn your
body and open up the run game and now
you're going to see the tape against
kentucky right here once again the
athleticism and the not the best balance
but does enough to get in the way
because he's so explosive at that second
second level of the defense so this is
what mcdaniel wants he needs guys that
can move and cole strange has shown that
he could do that and i wouldn't be
shocked if teams do draft him and try to
get a bargain center on the top of day
three in this trap
well speaking of bargain listen a
commenter already brought it up haskell
garrett
you think he's there at 125
i do i really do
if he's there at 125 you have to take
him he is he's i think he becomes
at best a rotational player excuse me at
worst a rotational player i think he can
compete for starting time based upon
what he's able to do haskell garrett's a
guy got to watch him coming out of high
school he's so
he's stout he's strong he's super
athletic for how big he is he's someone
that probably is i don't think he can
play a zero but i think he could play a
shade and he could definitely play all
the way out to a four eye he
wants to run around he has the ability
to see him here that's him right there
is a four being able to make that swim
to get penetration so yes we we i told
you we were going to talk about haskell
garrett nothing but good things to say
about a guy who's willing to obviously
get his hands up to block the to bat
down a pass someone that plays in gaps
better than he plays heads up i think
and i love the fact that if he can play
in a gap if you let him gap and not two
gap i don't mean a guy that has the get
extension read and direct you give him
hey listen on this play you're in the b
and this play you're in the c this
player in the a we're going to have you
slanting we're going to have you
stunning we're going to do those things
i think that's where haskell garrett
really shines
yeah fell there two things i loved on
that tape right because you you talked
about it we know he can one gap we know
when his hands are right he can keep
blockers off him and rush the passer
that's what he's going to do at the next
level two things on tape there what
happens when things don't go your way
right you saw the pursuit of the play
down the field excellent hustle and then
you saw he was blocked but got his hand
up and batted down a pass that's the nfl
things aren't always going to be perfect
what is the extra effort you're going to
do to show that even when you're not
winning in the initial step of the rush
how are you going to affect the play
that's great to see from haskell garrett
all right felder it's time for the jets
right a big uh
a big spot in this draft two top ten
picks something we don't see a lot in
the nfl draft both the jets and the
giants have that spot this year two more
picks in the top 40. felder how are we
kicking this thing off right now
so listen folks if you guys don't know
connor
lifelong jets fan works covers the jets
does everything for the jets so i'm not
gonna waste your time i'm just gonna
kick out two names right i'm gonna kick
out two names to connor i wanna see what
he likes as a fan so i can get the pulse
of that team that's something i try to
do all the time is take the pulse of the
team because a couple times i've made
pics for teams and they're like we don't
want that we want to we want to guard we
don't want this so connor knows best but
those two top 40 end of the top 40 picks
i'm going to slot in chad mumma and then
the last pick i'm going gonna slide in
bayless jones what do you think about
those and then take me through what you
want because chad boom is a guy we've
already covered we know what he can do
as a linebacker we know they need
linebacker help
we really do and i like that you went
this direction with mumma here felder
because cj mosley is the only capable
linebacker they have on the team right
now the rest are developmental guys and
mumma's plug and play ready to start
it's the ability to live on the inside
or run sideline to sideline in a cover
three scheme where you're working in a
lot of space and you've got to be able
to move and you see the downhill pursuit
right there builder wrap up make the
tackle so muma is a perfect fit probably
looking at pick 38 for him i don't think
he makes it to pick 69 i think mumma
looks like a lock to be a top 50 player
a starting linebacker from day one and
bilas jones maybe my favorite day threes
one of my favorite day three sleepers in
the strap not just what he does on
special teams but when tennessee was
able to get him the ball on easy touches
like this and even that supposed to be
an easy throw it was low this is what he
can do after the catch the burst the
contact balance miles jones there is a
lot more meat on the bone for him at the
nfl level and it's not just on special
teams this was a team that was able to
bring back braxton barrios on a two-year
deal but guess what you're always
looking for the next man up to get
cheaper at positions like slot receiver
like returner you bring in villas jones
it could be your backup slot this year
you could scheme some touches for him
and it's not going to cost you that much
you look at all the picks the jets have
in the fourth and fifth round i like the
bargain receiver there felder i know you
had one more name for me for the jets
here to help out the other side of the
ball who are you looking at
oh hooter did i have another name i i
literally don't think he's right off
king
ryan
yes oh yeah oh yes
i was gonna save him until the end but
yes kobe bryant it's been interesting to
watch kobe bryant because he's a guy
that some people had flirting with the
end of the first round uh two months ago
and now all of a sudden he's someone
that people are talking about as a third
round pick
like where do you is it 35 is it the 38
we talked about that with mumma where
does he fit for the jets is he last
until 69 where does he fit because if
he's lasting there you've got to take
him right
yeah i think it would be pick 69 and
they're in a unique position where
they're they hired greg scrugg
cincinnati's you know d-line coach
during these great years where they're
gonna have the rap on all of these
cincinnati defenders and all of them are
good and the jets got to coach kobe
bryant at the senior goal so they are
well aware of what he can do he's a
scheme fit and they like value at corner
not premium assets not premium picks
they'd be looking right at the top of
round three there let's dive into the
comments one more time you see the needs
here you see some of our projected fits
remember this is crash course we don't
just do round one players every week
over and over again we are trying to get
you ready for rounds one two three four
five six and seven of the nfl draft so
one more deep dive in the comments ryan
ribeiro says and felder i want to throw
this one to you because you have been on
this player for a long time do you think
the jets could target george pickens in
the top 40 or is he a later round target
that is
i think that's a you know depending on
how much what he ever gets paid that's a
million dollar question right because
i think that he certainly is a first
round talent
i don't know how long he lasts once we
get out of the first round especially
if we see
as we expect drake london chris olave
garrett wilson
um jameson williams and then we start to
see whether it's like do you wait until
after david bell is picked to pick him
do you wait until after skye moore is
picked to pick him do you wait until
after like those all those moving pieces
for for george pickens are gonna be the
he's not in charge of anything right now
he's in charge of if teams believe in
his
him being healthy and then also
can he be productive in our scheme
versus him not being productive in a
college scheme that didn't use him very
well i i think that obviously reading
the question again do you think that
jets could target george pigs in the top
40 i would love for them to do that i
think he's an exceptional player if you
can get him at 38 get him if he's there
yeah i say take him i think he is one of
those players that's gonna have
i think um
i'm not calling a direct parallel in
terms of the type of playing style but i
am saying that remember demarius thomas
right
guy that played in an option offense
in college and was not incredibly
productive but we saw those flashes i
think that's very similar to what george
pickens is looking at where he can come
out and have a really good career um
in the nfl because you're gonna you know
actually throw the football to him
yeah felder i love it he's one of the
wild cards of this draft i think he ends
up obviously a top 50 pick it's just how
high can he climb from there can he
sneak into the first round can he sneak
into the top 40. all i know is from
years of doing this the nfl loves size
and speed and especially size and speed
from powerhouse programs like in georgia
alright so
long show great show afc east breakdown
we got linebackers d-line we got a lot
more exciting things coming your way
because we will be live all three days
in the bleacher report app on the
bleacher report youtube for the nfl
draft you see it right there day one
uh 8 p.m eastern time rounds two and
three live every pick starting at 7 p.m
eastern time and then rounds four and
five on that saturday at noon team no
sleep going from day two to day three
this is my favorite event of the year
i'm so glad we've been able to
prepare the audience for what we're
gonna do and it gets more fun on all
three days of the draft because we grade
every pick we break down every fit with
the teams we do it with no commercials
and we're live for all three days so i'm
connor rogers the lead nfl draft analyst
here at bleacher report with stadium's
college football analyst michael felder
we are here every thursday 1pm eastern
time giving you a crash course on the
nfl draft we'll catch you next week same
time same place
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you